Bob: Hey, what's up, friend?
Mark: Hey, buddy!
Jack: Oh, god, can I not change the--
Bob: You are
terrifying.
Mark: You are equally as bad, I imagine.
Bob: I didn't mean to sprint at you so fast
Wade: Granny Nips, I don't know which one you are
Jack: I... What?
Wade: Oh, you're Granny Nips...
Jack: I'm Green!
Wade: Yeah. Your name's
Mark: *Laughter*
Mark: I've gotta
Mark: I've gotta some super boner pills
Mark: Oh this is wonderful
Jack: ohhhhoohoo- Why?
Jack: Why do I walk like a child?
Jack: Who learned how to walk?
Wade: You can sprint like a child who learned how to walk
Jack: Okay. How do I... how do I open doors and shit?
Wade: F
Jack: Okay
Wade: Some doors open automatically when you run at them.
Jack: Wait, the elevators say "to hell"?
Jack: Oh my god sprinting is OP
Wade: Yeah
Mark: *ooh*
Wade: There is a stamina bar though you see though
Bob: Oh god driving these wheelchairs is the
Bob: Wheelchairs is a nightmare
Mark: Oh my god
Wade: Webcams are being, like, left or something
Bob: The fuck is happening?
Mark: Ooh~
Jack: Where is people?
Mark: I dunno
Bob: Nowhere, don't worry about it
Wade: Where you at our dearest old people?
Mark: I dunno know but I wanted to show you guys something
Jack: I don't wanna get in your super boner. Do you have a super boner?
Mark: Woah, hey! Wait, c'mere I wanna show you somethin'!
Wade: Hey!
Jack: What is that?
Mark: I dunno. Somethin' cool. Just wait for it *laughing* Wait for it...
Wade: Oh he's hurting himself
Mark: *Laughing* Wait for it
Mark: Ah! There we go.
Jack: What the fuck? What are you doing?
Mark: I don't know, I bought some nippers.
Bob: How'd you get nippers?
Mark: I crafted em, with my hands!
Wade: I taped you up!
Mark: Oh thank you, you're so nice! :)
Wade: You're welcome, now get knocked out.
Mark: No! Why!? Oh this is fun. Ahahaha
Wade: Now you're going to the isolation chamber!
Mark: Ohoho, there's a lot of colors in this world now...
Jack: I'm a gastric lavage?
Mark: What's a gastric lavage?
Jack: I don't know it looks like a douche...?
Wade: Oh, time to go to our seduction, sedation, seduction rooms!
Mark: Seductive sedation room?!
Jack: What is happening?
Mark: I'm being dragged away, and I'm VERY druggy...
Jack: *Laughs*
Wade: Here we are! Enjoy the seduction room.
Mark: No no no no no nah na nah nahhh!!
Wade: Goodbye! :)
Mark: Damn it!
Bob: This is really fucked up...
Mark: Dude, I don't even know what I'm doing right now so...
Jack: This is such a weird game!
Bob: I lit myself on fire mark, what did you do?
Mark: I haven't done anything yet dude.
Jack: I'm sending you to hell apparently, you see that?
Bob: Wooooah woah woah woah woah I don't like this....
Wade: Goodbye! :)
Bob: You just sent me to hell, and now I respawn...
Mark: Wait, you went to hell?! Oh wait. Hang on. I might be on to something here...
Jack: Nippers lend me yo nippers.
Mark: Hey! Cool!
Wade: Someone crafted some poison..!
Mark: How do YOU know what I crafted?!
Wade: It tells us the...
Mark: BWWWWAAHHHHHthhAHHHbbBWWAHHHH!!!!!
Wade: OH NO!
Jack: NOOOOO!!!
Mark: UhhhhhAHHGGHHAHHH!!!!
Wade: Oh, God!
Jack: OLD  MAN JENKINS!
Mark: Oh, my GOD! That's so much vom!!!
Jack: I don't, I don't need to...
Mark:AAAAAAAAHHHHHHHUUUUU
Mark: Oh my, GAH-HA-HA, HOH MY GOD!!!
Bob: Jamal is dead?!
Jack: *Giggles*  Oh my Jesus.
*Mark laughs insanely, as usual*
Jack: What does a butt lavage do??
Mark: I don't know but I've got a pill of HumpPlus.....So that's a thing...
Jack: It's not dying. It says it's not dying when I tries to use it on you. Hahahaha.
Bob: No don't drag him in here-fuck man.
Mark: Sorry I didn't know, I didn't know. I didn't know!
Wade: Oooh someone crafted a razor blade!
Bob: I'm doing something here.
Wade: Oh no.
Mark: Ahhhhh!
Bob: What the fuck!?
Mark: Wait, so you can only get us when we craft something?
Wade: No we can get you any time.
Mark: Ahhhhh.
Jack: No we can we can see what you craft in the top right.
Mark: Ok.
*Incomprehensible*
Wade: So different things cure different ailments. We have to kinda guess what we think they're gonna craft.
Wade: Uhh. Bob might light himself on fire Jack, I'm gonna follow Mark around?
Mark: NO NO NO NO! You don't need to, You don't need to follow me nothin'.
Jack: Wait I...Ok I don't have the fire extinguisher anymore. OPEN THE FUCKING DOOR!
Wade: Oh. Don't you use that. I don't, I don't have a cure for whatever it is that you are holding.
Mark: Ok cool! :3
Bob: It's fine, don't worry about it...
Mark: NOO MY SUPER BONER
Wade: Oh YES!
Mark: My super boner!
Bob: Oh noo. Mark: AHHH!
Wade:You got the super boner....!
Mark: Bob go find the super boner. It's on the ground outside by the pool go get it, go get it!
Bob: I'm about to kill myself successfully Mark, don't worry about it.
Jack: Seth is dead, fuck's sake. Jamal has woken.
Mark: I'm woke.
Bob: It's out by the pool?
Wade: You know I don't even like this job. I don't know why I'm here...
Jack: *laughing* I got horny boy pills. Wait, take these. Mark you take these you seem, you seem to want to actually have fun.
Mark: Where?
Jack: Oh you have them, take them.
Mark: No-not there's more there's three different types.
Jack: Here's horny boy...
Mark: Ok so watch this. You guys are gonna see something amazing as soon as I find the third piece of the puzzle here.
Wade: What's the third one? We'll help you find it.
Mark: It's blue!
Mark: *old man voice* Bahhh you gonna help an old man get it up every once in a while
Jack: Hell yeah old man Jenkins!
Bob: If I-if I find blue i'll let you know Mark.
Mark: Alright, thank you.
Wade: There's like a storage room somewhere in here that has like all kinds of stuff.
Jack: If I find blue I'll come to  you. I FOUND 'EM I FOUND'EM I FOUND 'EM!!!
Mark: WRUUUU I'm by the pool.
Jack: I'm behind you, here you go. Old man Jenkins! Get that boner we all want!
Mark: Alright, I'll-
Bob:I want to see the boner.
Mark: I'll show it off.
Bob: Wait, are you guys at the pool?
Mark: Yeah, let me just.
Wade: Yeah we're at the pool
Mark: Hang on let me warm it up for you.
*Incomprehensible* Jack: Warm it up.
Jack: Come on over and see the boner
Everyone: Woah!
Bob: Oh my god!
Mark: I don't know what's happening!
Jack: You have steam coming out of everywhere!
Mark: *Werid orgasm sounds*
Bob: Holy shit!
Wade: Look at that boner!
Mark: Bwahhhh *laughs*
Wade: Oh no!
Bob: Hey i'm gonna cover him in stuff hang on it's fine, it's fine.
Mark: That was so sickening!
Jack: We only have 10 seconds left, I'm stuck!
Wade: Oh I've gotta sedate brother Mark!
Mark: Huh?  No you don't!
Bob: Jack I don't think you're gonna get me there buddy...
Jack: *screams*
Mark: I'm trying to do something. AWWWW fuck!
Bob: YEEEEEEaAeyeeeeey!?
Mark: I mean, yay! Wait no, that's yay.
Mark: That's our team.
Bob: That's yay? Okay.
Mark: You guys go, you guys be the other one..
Jack: This game is fucked up...
Mark: Yeah!
Jack: I'm an old man. I'mma kill myself!
Mark: No!
Mark: Don't do that.
Wade: Please let us die!
Mark: Do the opposite of that!
Jack: It's muffin time!
Wade: You all suckkkk!
Bob: How's it going?
Mark: Hey buddy, Hey!
Bob: What you doing here buddy?
Mark: Hey- oh. Whatchu crafting there, nippers?
Wade: Oh, nothing... Nothing.
Mark: Don't craft no nippers!
Bob: Trying to make some nippers there, Wade?
Mark: NononONONONONO
Mark: What? It didn't work, it didnt work!
Mark: AAAHH!   Jack: *laughter*
Mark: Oh no oh no- ah
Jack: AAAHH got my Nippers on. Nippin myself to death!
Mark: I don't, I don't have a med kit. Jack: TAKE ME AWAY!!
*Mark mutters Gibberish Markimoo things*  Wade: Wasn't that a thing??
Mark: No no-NOOOO!
Mark: Ah shit!
Mark: Shhhit
*Everyone mutters gibberish as Mark runs around*
Mark: Aaah. Jack: I nipped myself to death guys.
Shit.  Mark: NononononononononononononononoNO!
Mark: What the heck?! Wait-
Mark: D-d-d-d-d-don't- nononononono didalaydidalay Eah
Mark: How do I sedate you? There we go. There we go.. Jack: AAH
Mark: ayeya i got ya. Ya i got em. Jack: *mainly incomprehensible noises* Let me go!
Mark: Nah- You can't stop me now.
Mark: Jamal, come on.
Mark: Your having a little to much fun out there.
Bob: How did I find the sedation? I don't understand.
Mark: 'Scuse me, 'scuse me sir
Jack: Fuck 'em, fuck 'em! Seth, help me!!
Mark: Aaaannd, there. Have fun!
Jack: I went to hell. Mark: I know.
Bob: Hey, what's up?
Wade: How could you?!
Mark: *Laughs*
Bob: Mark wants to fuck Wade I think is what's going on. Mark: Pretty much.
Mark: God damn, who's makin' nippers?
Jack: Hey guys, I'mma just kill myself real quick!
Mark: Nah nah nah nah nah nah nah nah nah nah nah nah, where are you? Where are yo-
Mark: Jamal? Jamal? Bob: Where do you do that? Where do you do that? Just answer me that one question.
Jack: What?
Bob: Where you are.
Mark: Yeah where you are.
Jack: Uhh Gahh, I'm outside!
Mark: Where?
Jack: Over- across the water.
Mark: No no no no. Jamal, Jamal, JAMALLL!
Bob: Fucks sake!
Jack: I'm dead!
Jack: I did it! :3
Wde: I'm joining you soon Jamal.
Bob: I don't- I don't understand where anyone is, or whats happening...
Mark: Uh oh.
Mark: Oh, oh *says oh about 30 times*
Bob: Oh shit!
Bob: Where is that?
Mark: What do we need for that?
Bob: I have a glove, I just don't know where it is.
Mark: I'll look around.
Mark: Oh, oh gawd, oh, oh no.
Jack: Sorry guys!
Jack: Sorry!
Mark: No no no
Jack: Self-immolation for me!
Mark: No no. Where, just where though?
Mark: Just tell me where.
Jack: I'M NOT TELLING YOU WHERE! I LIKE BURNING ON MY OWN!
Mark: Where are you guys?
Mark: I cannot find any of you.
Wade: Umm, umm, you guys may have thought I didn't have all the things so-
Mark: Eh, ehh, GOTCHA!
Wade: Uhh, AWW NO!
Jack: *Laughs*
Mark: Yeah, I gotcha this time!
Wade: No, Jamal!
Wade: Jamal- *inaudible*
Mark: Oh, chh, there you are?
Wade: NO JAMAL NO!
*Everyone laughs as most of the audio isn't audiable.*
Mark: Yeah this game is garbage! *Laughs as Wade still screaming for him to stop*
Bob: This is- This is terrible!
Mark: Yeah. Wade: NOOOOOOOOO!